this episode of real engineering is
brought to you by brilliant a problem
solving website that teaches you to
think like an engineer in the past few
years there has been a lot of buzz
around the possibility of drone delivery
services most think companies like
Amazon will be the first to deploy them
in their distribution centers but few
realized the technology is already in
use for a far greater purpose in the
developing world more than 2 billion
people across the world lack access to
essential medical products like blood
and vaccines due to poor quality or even
non-existent infrastructure last month I
visited Rwanda with Sam from Wendover
productions and Joseph from real-life
lore we were all struck by how modern
and clean Kigali the nation's capital
was but just a short drive outside the
city the quality of roads deteriorated
quickly the country has been working
hard to improve their transportation
links over the past two decades but of
the 14 thousand kilometers of roads in
Rwanda only two thousand 600 kilometers
are paved the rest consists of uneven
dirt roads that become incredibly
difficult if not impossible to navigate
during the country's raining season we
got a taste of this while on safari when
our 4x4 got stuck in the mud forcing us
to get out and push
keep in mind we were looking for lines
on this trip medical supplies by nature
need to be on hand quickly if a mother
is bleeding out during childbirth she
cannot afford to wait three hours for
blood to arrive leaving people living in
remote rural villages in danger the zip
line the real reason we visited Rwanda
is working to solve this problem with
their fleet of autonomous drones each
capable of carrying 1.6 kilograms of
medical supplies about the weight of
three 500 milliliter blood bags these
amazing little drones have a ton of piki
engineering design that was influenced
by zip lines design philosophies several
unique factors influenced their designs
the first is the speed the plane needs
to get into the air the moment an order
comes in the clock has started and
zipline aims to have their drone in the
air in as short a time as possible this
is after all an emergency and seconds
count currently they are averaging just
five minutes from order to launch
that's the time it takes for in order to
arrive in their on-site pharmacy to
launch but for now let's focus on some
of the engineering challenges getting a
plane into the air that quickly is
pretty astounding somewhat struggle just
to get a drone out of its case and
flying in that time and zip line have
come up with some amazing solutions to
reduce those seconds just like a DJI
drone ziplines plane needs a GPS
connection in order to fly as they are
not piloted they're autonomous if you
have ever flown a drone you know it can
sometimes take a little while for the
drone to boot up and make a connection
with a GPS satellite so to remove that
delay zipline move the GPS circuitry
from the plane to the battery this means
it's always on and always connected
this innovation alone removed an average
of 10 to 15 minutes off the launch time
the battery is one of four pieces of the
plane that need to be assembled prior to
flight first the order is placed inside
the drop hatch of the fuselage which is
then placed on the launcher
the wings are then attached followed by
the battery this modular design makes
the plane much easier to handle allowing
staff to easily lift it into place more
importantly it separates components so
if there is a problem found with the
wings during the pre-flight check they
are simply swapped out without having to
start the entire assembly process over
again pre-flight checks are often a
lengthy process and zipline have come up
with some cool solutions to hasten this
step 2 checking the flight surfaces is
done with a mobile app that connects to
the launcher system the launch
technicians simply point the phone's
camera a QR codes on each control
surface sending a message to the plane
to actuate the control surface that the
phone then use Liza's a computer vision
algorithm to make a pass or fail
judgment for each control surface once
the plane is ready and assembled on the
launcher the next time saving measure
kicks into gear rather than telling you
how this works I'm going to show you
we spent two days at zipline and this
never got old the rail uses a pulley and
an electric motor to quickly and safely
get the drone up to speed
accelerating the plane to its 100
kilometer per hour cruising speed in
just 0.3 seconds it launches the same
way every time and reliably clears the
obstacles in front of it takeoff and
landing are the most difficult stages of
a flight to avoid having to land at the
destination the plane simply drops the
supplies in an insulated car board box
with a simple parachute which can then
be thrown away meaning the clinic's
needed no infrastructure to sign up as
the client of the distribution center
when the plane does eventually need to
land the procedure to allow it to land
with no pilot is even more incredible
once again I think it's easier to just
show you how it works
it may be difficult to keep track of
everything that happened there so here
it is again in slow motion there is a
small hook at the end of the tail boob
which will grab the wire strung between
the two actuated arms on either side of
the capture system it's hard to see in
real-time but in slow motion you can
clearly see that the arms actually raise
up at the last moment to catch the hook
the plane is communicating its location
in 3d space with the radio receivers
next to the platform allowing the wire
to stay out of the way until the last
moment minimising any risk of collision
with the wire the capture system misses
about ten percent of the time but the
plane is programmed to immediately
detect a miss and throttle up its
engines to gain altitude and make
another pass an older design of this
system had a retractable tail hook the
caught and actuated wire closer to the
ground which then slowed the plane down
enough for it to land softly on an
inflatable pod this system was fraught
with design issues when it rained the
inflatable would pool with water which
was no problem for the waterproof plane
but forced the staff to crawl through it
and lift a relatively heavy plane it was
neither comfortable or economic the
retractable tail boom needed a motor to
control the retraction which could fail
an added weight compared to the simple
metal hook attached to the carbon-fiber
tail boom of the current generation
plane factoring safety into an
autonomous drone Network is another
unique factor that has shaped ziplines
designs the zipline works on a
philosophy of redundancy of parts in
order to ensure safety it has to of
everything to motors when it only uses
one during flight to of every actuator
and if somehow two of something breaks
the plane will automatically deploy a
parachute allowing it to softly
touchdown back to earth this procedure
can also be initiated by the control
tower if a command from the airspace
authorities is received as a result of
this focus on safety zipline has had
zero accidents causing injury since they
started service in October 2016 the next
design factor which will be common to
any aeronautical design is the weight of
the aircraft and in turn its range
zipline uses planes because quad copters
use far more energy to fly and just
can't get the range necessary from
batteries
are relatively slow these planes cruise
at 100 kilometers per hour with a range
of 160 kilometers allowing the drone to
serve an 80 kilometer zone around this
location the inner skeleton consists
nearly entirely of lightweight
carbon-fiber composites which is then
covered in a lightweight foam shell
which is easy and cheap to replace if it
gets damaged as a result the entire
fuselage weighs just six point four
kilograms the wings way to kilograms
with a wingspan of three meters the
structurally integral wing spar that is
the beam that runs along the length of
the wing is also made from high-strength
carbon-fiber composite with the
aerodynamic surfaces being formed with
high-density polystyrene and 3d printed
plastics the batteries are by far the
heaviest part of the vehicle making up
half of the total weight of the aircraft
at 10 kilograms the zipline employed
lithium-ion batteries with a total
capacity of 1.25 kilowatt hours for
comparison a Nissan Leaf has 24 kilowatt
hours and your average Tesla has about
120 as mentioned before these removable
sections earned just batteries they
contained the GPS circuitry but also
include the data storage that hold the
flight data from all the sensors onboard
the moment the battery is hooked up to
charge at this charging station the data
begins to pour into zipline servers for
every hour of flight these drones
generate one gigabyte of data this for
me is ziplines greatest assets these
drones don't just face engineering
challenges but regulatory challenges to
fitting a large autonomous network of
drones into an already busy and highly
regulated American airspace would be
incredibly difficult Rwanda serves as
not just a worthy cause but a valuable
testbed for integrating and network of
autonomous drones into a country's air
traffic control zipline communicates
directly with Rwanda central air traffic
control in Kigali Airport in the
nation's capital having this testbed in
my mind is more valuable than any
hardware technology zipline has
developed rhinox in Horn one of ziplines
founders gave us a guided tour when we
arrived he ziplines head of software and
has worked tirelessly to make ziplines
autonomous drone control system the best
in existence a quick look through
patents attributed to Ryan will uncover
a slew of designs related to automate
drone management systems like Payton
triple nine seven zero eight zero
decentralized air traffic management
system for unmanned aerial vehicles
which describes software solutions to
allow multiple UAVs which have no way of
detecting other UAVs in their airspace
to avoid collisions this testbed and
data is going to allow zipline to
continue to churn out designs and
concepts to optimize the control of the
drone delivery network and ultimately
allow them to expand into new
territories with busier air spaces this
month they are expanding within Rwanda
opening a second location to serve the
east of Rwanda this could eventually
grow into a supply chain allowing drones
to hop between bases getting their
batteries swapped out in a couple of
minutes and be on their way this
technology is useful outside of just
developing countries it could be used in
disaster relief scenarios when roads
become impassable due to flooding it
also allows supplies to be centralized
hospitals often have to carry more
medical supplies than they need keeping
stocks of medical supplies which short
shelf lives inevitably leads to waste
incredibly expensive wastes that cost
the taxpayer money this is the problems
if line could potentially reduce by
allowing centralization of emergency
supplies that can be quickly dispatched
when needed when quarantines are an
issue these drones could minimize human
exposure to contagious diseases and so
help stop the spread of disease these
are both scenarios that Wendover
productions and real-life flora explore
in their videos released today we could
not have made this trick without the
help of brilliant so if you'd like to
see more videos like this
please check them out if you have an
interest in this kind of design I would
highly recommend you take this course on
classical mechanics which will form the
bedrock of understanding for you to
start applying physics like figuring out
how much batteries to include for a
drone design this is just one of many
courses on brilliant with more courses
due to be released soon on things like
automotive engineering and Python coding
if you've been inspired and want to
educate yourself then go to brilliant
org ford slash real engineering and sign
up for free and the first 73 people that
go to that link will get 20% off the
annual premium subscription as always
thanks for watching and thank you to all
my patreon supporters
you'd like to see more from me the links
to my Instagram Twitter subreddit and
discord server are below
you